un grupo de militares que actuó como un
escuadrón del terror en compañía de
otros agentes del Estado e incluso
civiles fue en particular una brigada
del ejército la que azotó el
departamento del casanare al este de
Colombia presentando falsos positivos 22
militares dos civiles y un agente de
inteligencia hicieron parte de esa
brigada la 16 y este lunes Fueron
imputados por crímenes de guerra y lesa
humanidad por parte de la jurisdicción
especial para la paz un tribunal que
busca arrojar luz sobre la cerca de seis
décadas de guerra en el país y que nació
fruto de los acuerdos de paz de 2016 en
la brigada 16 se implantó una
organización criminal una organización
criminal compleja que se valió de la
arquitectura institucional del ejército
para presentar asesinatos y
desapariciones forzadas como bajas en
combate en casanare
los crímenes en cuestión se cometieron
entre 2005 y 2008 bajo el mandato del
derechista Álvaro Uribe Vélez según la
jep los imputados de este lunes
participaron en el asesinato de 303
personas en lo que apunta a una conducta
masiva dice el tribunal especial su
premio eran reconocimientos permisos
especiales o planes vacacionales la
mayoría de los fallecidos eran hombres
entre 18 y 25 años pero en este caso
también se asesinaron a nueve mujeres
una de ellas en estado de embarazo y
también un joven de orientación sexual
diversa siendo esta la primera vez que
la jep imputa un crimen de lesa
humanidad por razones de género
también determinó que la deliberada
manipulación o instrumentalización de
personas vulnerables por sus condiciones
socioeconómicas o por discapacidades
cognitivas
ayudó a consolidar la idea de que las
personas en estas condiciones son
prescindibles en la sociedad entre los
imputados figura un mayor general dos
coroneles y tres tenientes coroneles
todos en retiro en las próximas semanas
a los señalados deben reconocer o
rechazar sus cargos y podrían ser
condenados a 20 años de